(Mitch) We've shown you over the past year the ins and outs of some crazy science
But have you ever wondered about these hands?
Or how are these videos made?
You're about to know!
(Snazzy)
(Greg) Hi I am Greg (Mitch) and I am Mitch, and we are creators of AsapScience
We thought it would be nice to give you guys behind the appearance of driving
In how to create episodes, who we are, and what to do.
(Greg) instead of doing "draw my life", why we always draw our own science videos
We do "real life my life"
We put a video asking you guys to ask us questions
So we will answer some questions
We'll give you a little backstage about how to create our own videos
That is what we will do today
(Mitch) so the first question is "Which country do you live in?"
(Greg) 1, 2 and 3 (both) Canada!
(Mitch) "What is your educational background?"
(Greg) so I went to the University of Guelph
Where I studied biological sciences and said in an art studio
After that, I went to the Teachers' College, where I learned to become a teacher
At UFT at the University of Toronto
Last year, I was already in the UK studying people at the academy. Shout!
(Mitch) also went to the University of Guelph and got a degree in biological science
Obviously I am less educated because this is where it ended for me
But then I worked in some laboratories and
(Greg) Simple Mind (Mitch) Yes, a simple mind
(Greg) the next question "What made you start the channel?"
(Mitch) Well, we thought YouTube was great
We have seen some other educational channels, which we think are very effective
We believe that we love science. We love to explain science to people.
Why not start this channel that looks like "fast access science"
More specifically for people who do not believe they love science
We thought it would be nice to communicate with people who think science is boring
Or I think science absorbs or never reaches as far as we can find these really wonderful things
When you are in high school sometimes the science may seem boring
They do not teach you really wonderful things.
(Greg) I think one of the first ideas we had
We had a lot of friends around us, and what we would do when we were lounging was
Explain to them specific scientific concepts we know in a simple way
Which we thought would involve them
That was one of our first lamps, when we thought
"We are likely to do so in a center where more people can reach it"
So the question is "How did you think and formed the slogan of AsapScience?"
(Mitch) so we had a big scheme, like, science-related names
As you know, there was, for example, a couple we wanted and the YouTube channel was already transferred
(Greg) Some very bad!
'but how?' (Mitch) was like "ever wonder?"
"Quick Science" (Greg) No, "Ever Wonder" was good
(Mitch) Yes (Greg) Kadana We did "surprised"
(Mitch) So, in the end, we were like AsapScience.
We are a fan of A $ AP Rocky and we were like us
This beautiful name is sweet and like
"As soon as possible" It was cool.
This type of message conveyed the message we were trying to address
(Greg) but "not" the dollar sign in our country
(Mitch Muffin) Yes, unfortunately, we do not make as much money as him.
In terms of logo, if you watch our first video
We did not even have a logo, we just painted it, the name of AsapScience.
In my opinion, I was like "every time we change it"
So, our audio track ended up creating an AsapScience logo
But then we got a little laziness and then we just decided to use those clips
Again and again, and then ended up becoming our motto forever
(Greg) How do you choose your subjects?
(Mitch) Well, when we started at the beginning, we had a list of things
We went out before we even start the channel
The things we thought were cool from the university or friends I had asked before
So we just compiled a large list
(Greg) You're all criticized through Facebook and Twitter
In fact YouTube comments
So I spend a lot of time reading all comments on Facebook and YouTube comments
I have a list on my phone with 275 really genius themes
I've thought about you, so this is something we really do
"What is video making?"
(Mitch) Why do not we go to show you?
(Very cheerful music)
So this space our office
We have a new office space
(Greg) Im tired
So the first step is to discover an idea
So, sometimes on the basis of breakthroughs in science that we see interesting
Or the books we read. Or what happens is that a lot of time do not know everything
So we get a lot of great ideas from you, and we have to know what the answers are
And how we will actually create a video of information
This involves research. The second step is to do research
Books, and a lot of online time using peer-reviewed journals and art material
We love using PubMed, Google Scholar, and websites that can reach us with these types of information
(Mitch) we have a lot of tags
We are in business marks.
Unfortunately, everyone had to be kept in the original, and began to drive them out after they started to dry out
I usually set them up here and I have everything ready to go
Millions of signs of blackboard board.
Ill make their cemetery one day.
Generally once our script, I just come here.
We do not actually finish the script until we draw
Therefore, we have the camera pointing down on the blackboard.
And you can only draw
(Greg) so although Mitch was relying on a lot of whiteboard this year
Originally we had an idea about the type of animation and explain science through art
Because, in fact, I am an artist. In a lot of the time, I would like to combine art and art together
So these are the paintings I made from proteins
Optical images of proteins are through a program called PIMAL
They are very precise and complex, so I used them
Then painted on canvas using oil paint
And finally this is Björk who is a great inspiration for us. The art and science blend in a very special way
We really look into
(Mitch) So, this is our most distinguished, most modern Estudione.
As you can see, all the things you need. Clothing on the left.
Towels and blankets on the right.
I make it mainly with blankets and stuff, just to cool the noise, right?
Because you want to get a room where there is not much echo, you can get only dry sounds
"Dreams are an amazing phenomenon, given that you spend nearly 6 years of your dream life
It is very strange that we often clean them aside to be quickly forgotten.
But, what are dreams?
Like many science fiction stories or movies, we can record them at all
And know what we see at the time we dream it? "
Basically, you can bring stills - so we have a lot of different sections of the video
We have a different voice that I have edited now
So I have to match the video clips with the recorded sound.
So not the other way around. Some people think I'm talking to video footage.
But instead, we record one audio track when I come
Take video and type of stream all together with different clips.
Adds up to the timing of the video
(AsapScience music is very passionate and cool)
So the last step is to add music. Usually we use the original song that you wrote
But every now and then I feel like I'm writing a new song or adding a new song that fits this video perfectly.
So, I'm a musician and I have a musical background.
You can check my own stuff at mitchellmoffit.com
To listen to my music there. It was a nice way to integrate my own interests into videos
We have kind of music and science to cooperate in AsapScience channel.
(Superior techno rad)
"So, what are your jobs outside of AsapScience? Ive always wanted to know."
(Greg): I just completed a year of teaching abroad in the UK.
In a place called Folkestone where I taught science.
It was a really wonderful experience. I actually got to do practical experiments
And interact with the classroom well.
In addition to the side I will go home and I will help with this YouTube channel
And involve millions of people.
(Mitch) a year ago, we did not really know that this might be work
Like, you just start for fun and then pick it up.
Now both of our full-time jobs. (Greg) all of the full-time jobs, yes.
"Are you planning to collaborate with SciShow, Vsauce, MinutePhysics, or any other site?
Channels related to science?
(Mitch) Yes, we absolutely love it. I mean we have a chance to cooperate with Vsauce3, Jake.
We hope to do it again. We also have to cooperate with Bill Nye!
Our dream has become a reality, which is really wonderful.
"Have you ever tried to tell who has videos?"
(Greg) his voice number is much better than my voice.
Two of them, and true, I sounded like a badger honey.
"Ever wonder why both coffee and alcohol have an unfortunate tendency to make you urinate?"
(Mitch) "reveal one of your biggest secrets"
(Greg) Um ...
Oh my God, I can not think of any occasion.
(Mitch) Yes, you do not have to answer
(Greg) "Please sing to us in this voice, Mitchell, that would be very fun"
(Mitch) Um ... what? Song periodic table?
(Greg) or like Whitney Houston
(Mitch) no
(Greg) "Where did you learn how to draw?"
(Mitch) I did not do that. Like, I just, Greg actually has an art degree.
But it was in a different country so I had to start painting and it was like drawing
So, I just want to look for different images of animation and try to think of them
Try to make it as simple as possible, which is added to our aesthetics
(Greg) Everyone says "Oh, I cant do art". Anyone can do art.
It is only practice. You are only teaching yourself. It is only a knowledge to make you a painter.
(Mitch) "What's your favorite movie?"
(Greg) 2001 "The Odyssey Space" by Stanley Cooper
For reasons we all know
"What is your favorite game?"
(Mitch) Zelda! In the best video game ever. I'm obsessed with it.
I have played all the Zelda game, and its awesome.
So "Does it change your search for your videos?"
(Greg) Yes, I think it is. For example: after we did the scientific power of napping
We power plugs Gorse now
In fact, I have an electric nap every day and I always make sure they are less than 20 minutes
I honestly think they help.
Coffee and alcohol, consume a lot. (Mitch) Yes
Cure for Headache (Greg) Pee a lot ... treat a headache!
(Mitch) and things like productivity. You learn about him then you want, or procrastination
You're like, "I can not procrastinate now, I've said like a million people to stop procrastination"
(Greg) Then there are tips. In many of our videos, we provide tips and examples of things to do
It is much easier to follow now. I mean, we learn as we do these videos
Just as you learn when you see them and certainly affect our lives.
Hopefully the same way it affects.
(Mitch) Thanks for watching this special episode of AsapScience!
(Greg) and if you want to follow us on Instagram or Twitter personally
The links will be in the description below
(Mitch) As always, I got a flaming question? Ask them in comments, on Facebook and Twitter
Subscribe to more weekly science videos!
(Have you clicked on it yet?)
(They were waiting ...)